hello and welcome to the show my guest
today is an Englishman who I think must
have an identical twin or a clone or
something because he has achieved so
much in his life so far I don't know how
he's found the time
Daniel Hope is a broadcaster he directs
and produces short films he's artistic
director of music festivals he writes
books and scripts and a really good blog
incidentally he's a charity fundraiser
and I haven't mentioned the fact that
he's actually best known as one of the
world's top solo violinists welcome to
the program thank you for your time is
it really you or is it your identical
twin it's definitely me well we'll find
out later because I know you're going to
play live on the program as well so I'm
sure your are identical twin can't do
that as well as you can I am intrigued
though I mean there's things I haven't
mentioned I know you're visiting
professor at the Royal Academy of Music
as well in London when do you find the
time to actually practice the violin
first thing in the morning it's what
defines my day you know an instrument
like the violin you have to be in tune
in the best sense you have to be able to
play the pieces you can't have a career
if you can't play the instrument and so
therefore you have to make sure you have
enough time to practice the good thing
about the violin is that you can
practice almost anywhere and because I'm
on the road a lot that means hotels
mostly in bathrooms in hotels because
you have a door you can you know shut it
I have a practice mute that goes on
there so it doesn't disturb the
neighbors and I can literally practice
absolutely anywhere and tend to do that
but it's it's what starts my day because
you know you if you make mistakes and
some of the other genres or other
disciplines I can just about get away
with it because that's not what I really
do I'm a musician I'm a violinist but
with the violin no one's gonna forgive
you so you know practice is important
okay now your life has changed a lot
recently and I again wondering how you
get the time because you recently got
married it's a wonderful picture of your
wife your little boy
that's right Anthony yes Anthony and I'm
so are you intending or indeed slowing
down with your extraordinary schedule
you know firstly you know where we are
bathing in the the wonderful arrival of
our son is now almost nine months old
and I took the first three months off to
be there
I cancelled everything and I was just at
home which was a wonderful time for me
and we decided to see you know how it
would go with travel on how he would
take to it if he's okay with travel and
the first sign so that he's even better
than I am of the whole yeah so at the
moment I haven't really done much
slowing down once I went back to work
after the three months we've been
traveling together which and and that's
that's gone very very well indeed so
we'll see what happens yeah yeah now the
guests on this show are normally
foreigners who live in Germany and we
have to come clean and say you actually
live in Vienna which is a
german-speaking country but you have a
very special connection with this city I
know concerning your family and we'll
talk about that in just a minute but I
did want to ask you about one special
occasion where I believe you were the
first musician about four years ago to
play in the German parliament in the
Bundestag on a very special occasion I'm
not sure if I was the first musician I
could imagine they're happy another
musicians to play there but certainly it
was an amazing opportunity for me to be
there and very moving it was the
Holocaust Memorial Day in the Bundestag
and the entire German government was
there and also a number of of invited
guests Shimon Peres for example also
Holocaust survivors and there I was able
to to perform and also even to make a
very brief speech so it was a very
moving moment for me and in a sense a
way of
I am connecting to my roots which go
back to to Berlin in particular yeah
well tell us a bit about those roots I
mean I've seen the speech it was very
moving to me actually because you
dedicated I think that you're playing
and what you played was extraordinary or
is it was it your grandfather and your
great-great grandfather
it was both great-grandfather's that
both lived in Berlin yeah and they were
both extremely patriotic Germans who had
converted to Christianity in the 19th
century were decorated have for their
service in the First World War and when
Hitler came to power found themselves
foul of their Nuremberg rules and
tragically one took his own life because
he couldn't bear to the thought of
leaving Germany was it was too painful
for him so he in fact killed himself
here in in Berlin and the other one died
because he lost everything he had a
villa in dalam and a factory and that
was Aryan eyes
and the family had to flee and that
broke him so both of them who who loved
Berlin and who felt absolutely very
proud to be German went through this
terrible experience and so the thought
of their great-grandson standing up in
front of the entire German parliament in
the Vice tug and performing I thought
was something which was particularly
special so I dedicated it to both of
their memories yeah well as she doctor
Deutsche Welle filmed you when you
visited the villa that belonged to your
family back in 2007 and we found that
report let's see some of it now
Daniel hope visited the villa for the
first time during a concert tour it made
him more aware of how little his family
spoke about its past in Berlin there was
generally silence about what happened in
this dark chapter of Germany's past the
coat of arms are still there today
bearing witness to a family of
industrialists with a proud tradition
hopes great-great grandfather founded an
engineering Factory in Berlin and bought
the villa for his son in his book hope
combines family history with political
realities evoking the ingenuity of the
people of the villa minion era the music
of time for me and sugar is both a
historical document and a search for
personal identity in Vienna I've always
had a sort of high Mart feeling a
feeling of belonging a FIFA when I
finished the book and I knew how strong
the connection was with Germany for so
many of my family then I felt even more
at home here somehow here not all are
hungry little remains of the villas
former splendor today it's used as a
guest house by the German archaeological
Institute hopes great-grandfather took
his own life during the Nazi
dictatorship his widow and their
children were able to escape to South
Africa but they lost almost all their
property now Daniel hope knows that
after 1939 the villa was a Jewish school
a refuge for Jewish children then the
school was closed and most of the
children deported
Hitler's foreign minister York in front
a hidden top took over the villa and
turned it into a code-breaking center
Daniel hope tells these stories without
bitterness he's fascinated by how much
his family has been affected by the
twists and turns of fate his father's
ancestors fled Ireland during the famine
all the strands came together in South
Africa on the Irish side there was
always plenty of music and whiskey
everyone played an instrument or sang
the next twist of fate was in 1975 when
Daniel hopes family opposed to South
Africa's of
apartheid system left for England his
mother became secretary to the legendary
violinist Yehudi Menuhin Daniel Hoch
more or less grew up in my new ins house
and was encouraged and supported by his
musical foster father
Elita skinned it so ha my mom loved
having children in the house who are
always playing fantastic so I grew up
with these fantastic musicians and
people who came to visit like Ravi
Shankar Stephane Grappelli and
Rostropovich they came every day to
rehearse and they played with us as well
on Madonna should be now Daniel hope is
our guest today on inside Germany and I
just want to ask you have you been back
to the villa since that time yes I go
regularly actually when I when I'm in
Berlin I try and go there it's it's run
now by the German archeological
Institute which is a fantastic
organization and they've been extremely
friendly to me
they've always allowed me access to go
in and see in fact the coat of arms that
was mentioned there is the same one
that's on my ring which I I have which
is my grandmother's ring who lived in
that house so the connections is it how
do you feel when you are you obviously
like to go there and feel I do like to
go there yeah I mean I like to go and
try and soak up the atmosphere but the
fact that you know it went from my
grandmother's house to a Jewish school
where people like Mike Nichols was a
pupil Michael bloomin tile also our
pupil there Wow but then to this Center
for code-breaking activity a kind of
German Bletchley Park is really quite
strange and there is a rather strange
atmosphere there I find at least perhaps
up because I know the history but I'm
still very pleased that I was able to
discover all of this you said you were
you were pleased to be able to play in
the Bundestag I mean I wanted you also
sent us this picture this
here you are emblazoned across the
entire Brandenburg Gate actually that
what was that occasion that must have
been you must have thought right yeah
right this is I hope grand added yeah
looking at this yeah well this was a
concert organised by the city of Berlin
on the 9th of November last year 2013 to
commemorate the 75th anniversary of the
rice crystal
and it was actually amazing we took over
the entire Polly's our plots in front of
the Brandenburg Gate and on to the gate
were projected images of musicians and
artists that were kicked out of Berlin
after Costin art so you had these
extraordinary huge canvases with vanilla
cat hymen and valtor Yurman and all
sorts of musicians whom I admire and
composers remembered in that way and I
was asked to perform in front of this so
that was really quite an amazing thing
mmm now go back to your childhood was
mentioned there in the report you were
born in South Africa but in fact I think
your father it sort of runs in the fact
your father had to get out of South
Africa's he was against the apartheid
regime what did he do actually my
father's a writer and he was at the time
extremely politically active
he created a magazine called bolt in the
mid-seventies which published works of
black writers and as a result put him in
very hot water very soon my parents were
tailed their phones were tapped and they
were really put under enormous amount of
pressure and as a result they decided to
leave the country but they could only do
this if my father gave up his passport
so it was a one-way ticket that he was
given basically to Europe and we ended
up in Europe where we were ran out of
money very quickly it was impossible for
my father to find job and one day my
mother went out and and decided she
would use her secretarial skills that
she had and the fact that she spoke or
speak six languages to try and get some
kind of a job just to make ends meet and
that was when this extraordinary meeting
happened with a temp agency
director who I think took a shine to her
and said I have two part-time jobs which
are quite special one is secretary to
the Archbishop of Canterbury and the
other one is secretary to Yehudi Menuhin
and this is a temporary
yeah and the strange thing was that they
my mother and my father in fact had
heard the then Archbishop of Canterbury
when he came to South Africa and they
were absolutely shocked by his Pro
apartheid stance and as a result they
said my mother said there's no way I'm
ever going to work for this man but you
D Menuhin was of course completely
different she knew his name he'd she'd
seen him perform in South Africa she
admired him so she thought why not and
the missus presumably how you came to
playing the violin or that you we heard
your family old musicians and well then
Irish sorry I recite the late music
because you know in Ireland song and
dance is is you know absolutely part of
life but there are no musicians actually
in the family so the musical input I
think came from a kind of an osmosis
growing up in Union men you into a house
and what should have been a job lasting
six months turned into 26 years oh
really that long oh I know we have a
picture of you with menuing of course
and and you play you started playing
concerts with him I believe from the age
of eleven awesome when I was eleven we
did a very brief a performance together
but the real concert I sing started when
I was 16 it started kind of just more or
less when that photo was taken because
at that stage he had started to really
take an interest until that moment I
don't think he'd really necessarily
taken it seriously yeah apart from the
fact he was much you know that the boss
of my mum he thought it was more
important for me to find my own way and
to have my own teachers and I did and I
went to study with one of the greatest
teachers in the world Zaha Braun in
Lubec and that was my first real
introduction to Germany coming to do
back to study getting to know Braun and
Menuhin had heard about Braun and some
of his wonderful students and I think
was curious and when I was sixteen
seventeen asked me to come play for him
and from that moment on he realized I
did take it seriously and I did want to
be a violinist did I mean growing up
like that did you I mean do you get
nervous before performance I imagine
because you've been performing since
that age and you know with the great
water the greatest violinist of all time
on the other violin so to speak just to
nerves not play a role anymore nerves do
play a role and you know I think it's
it's it's a question of learning how to
cope with them I mean you yourself are a
performer you know what that means if I
don't feel anything going into a concert
then I get worried actually because I
don't want to be too relaxed and yet I
can never allow the nerves or the
tension to overcome the situation and
it's keeping control so I actually quite
enjoy that nervous feeling that you get
as the German seifuku I get involved and
being able to do controlled it at the
same time and use it because for me
there's nothing greater than being on
the stage yeah talking about you wrote a
book what a yes I say you man and many
times wrote a book called TOI TOI TOI
which is German for good luck really
before you go on stage today yeah which
is sort of anecdotes yes of things that
went wrong on stage I wonder if you have
one special one we haven't got time for
them all is the one you can think of it
there are several actually that one that
that I was told to me because it's a
collection of you know famous musicians
and composers came about five hundred
years they're also things that happened
to me in the book but one which I always
chortle over is one that sting told me
in fact he was watching the television
in the late 70s and it was BBC Proms
concert in the Royal Albert Hall and it
was some big choral work where they had
solo singers and in the middle of this
piece one of the singers was taken ill
and collapsed and this was all live on
the television so this poor fellow was
carried out you know on a stretcher out
of the Albert Hall and the audience was
sort of milling around and nobody knew
what sort of to do whereupon a young
singer standing in the promenade has put
up his hand
said oh I know the part I can sing it
where a boss two minutes later they got
him up onto the stage two huge applause
he was there in jeans and he took over
the role and sang oh no I thought that
was such a mixture of opportunism and
total anarchy at the same time and I've
had that story checked a few times it's
true I've heard I've heard it I've heard
the story as well yeah now I want to
talk to you about a project that I know
has been dear to your heart for a long
time forbidden music is a music composed
by prisoners in the tourism stat
concentration camp tell us how that came
about many of these ideas come about
through curious coincidence and in this
case I was driving home after a concert
one night listening to the radio and a
piece of music came on which I didn't
know when I hear a piece of music that I
don't know I try and guess who had
written it and it was 20th century it
had the elements of Stravinsky Bartok
but I knew it couldn't have been these
composers it was a string trio and they
didn't write one and I was so just
transfixed with the music that I
actually pulled over to wait to hear who
it was and the presenter said that was a
piece by giddy on climb I had absolutely
no idea who giddy on plan was but I
thought this piece is amazing so once I
got home I started to research little
bit and I found out Gideon Klein was a
twenty three four year old composer who
was imprisoned interesting start and who
not only composed music there but was
responsible as a kind of a motor to
encourage the other prisoners some of
whom were very famous composers to
return to making music and that set me
on a journey is 15 years ago of learning
the music researching meeting survivors
putting on concerts making recordings
recently we made a film where we spoke
to two surviving musicians so it kind of
one thing led to the next as it often
does with me well let's weave hears more
about the project beginning with my
guest meeting an extraordinary lady
who survived this ghetto in what was
then Czechoslovakia by playing the piano
from Earth it is directed into the
ceiling really is melty survey
with ice music I get born outside then
finish that music thank ba argentina
slim get hurt Cassidy and innocent
hockey analyst - uncle not really as if
you had another balance and it's really
uncommon when Irish King the mastaba on
Suzanne Godwin was for a nickname and a
foolish love ban punch like lesson and
then be here a new comment coffeehouse
really and that's moonshine financing
fine doctor first absorption concern
assignments and coffeehouse gift yeah
the oft capacity consetta the okay the
oft capacity concerta
yet not in and huge p lentivirus
dirt leash debris show him what a beast
so it is not for God and then he away
via as mentioned here yet since noise
music areas mentioned have money for and
vote on digger sister am Laden so how
vile is ended quasi austere suppose own
venison cocoa through one or an Alice
had some unleash my gift ma million each
does public um a hunter Dworkin mom
artists need providers public on the
shaman's also known in the the Highland
the craft Emily order
my laughing combusted
you said they're about keeping the music
alive I mean you're still doing concerts
I know
what did the reaction from people I mean
have you had some interesting stories
people coming up to you after concerts
oh yes
you know I say that the most moving ones
are when you have survivors who actually
interested at who come to you and you
know add to thank you for what you do or
tell you other things or an
extraordinary thing happened in in
Sweden one of the composers who we play
was a a nurse called is a Weber and she
did not survive but her music we play a
lot and her son came in fact to the
concert and one of the pieces that we
play is dedicated to her son and so he'd
been present in our minds and in our
soul if you like but then actually see a
man in his 80s or 85 standing in front
of you saying I'm the one in the song
that really was amazing hmm the the
lovely lady now Alice had sama is sadly
not with us anymore but she did live to
the grand old age of a hundred and ten
indeed they say she's the oldest
survivor
oh yeah Holocaust I'm an amazing woman
she she she said a number of things I've
said I'm Jewish but Beethoven is my
religion what about you his bait is
Brahms your religion I say music is my
religion for sure yeah yeah she also put
her long life down to being an optimist
I mean you've researched and gone into
these difficult times of your family and
of their having bit of you very much an
optimist so absolutely absolutely I
think not to be is is it's very
dangerous particularly in today's world
again it's extraordinary about that
music there was a that we didn't hear it
in that report but on the CD there's a
song I like so much that answer FIFA
notice things called
is it called Rogalla fear school vegan
because it's quite beautiful and I
wonder how do you think people can write
such beautiful things in such appalling
circumstances I don't think any of us
can know that you know we can we can
only guess and we can try and and put
ourselves in that position but we'll
never be in it I think it's incredible
that these prisoners had the courage to
go on to write even though many of them
must have known they would not survive
and yet they used music in order to
escape and in order to forget at least
for a moment where they were coming back
to your family there was one photo you
sent and I I didn't know what it was and
I asked she just before the program this
photo this is of your father at a
cemetery tell it tell us the rest of the
story when I started to write them for
that first book in 2007 4 million should
occur I really went back into the whole
family history my mother's side but my
father's side the Irish side and my
grandfather was a fighter pilot
he was South African but of Irish
descent and he volunteered to join the
British Air Force in the Second World
War and was sent out to North Africa
where as a very young man just in his
early 20s he was shot down and killed
and my father never knew his father he
was a baby
when his father died and he also never
knew where his grave was and when I
wrote the book I decided to try and find
his grave so I went to the Commonwealth
War Graves Commission website and I
entered the surname of my grandfather
and the day on which he died and it
popped up that he was in a military
cemetery in Israel at the time Palestine
but the town of Ramallah which is about
a 30 minute drive from Tel Aviv
so a couple of years ago I decided to go
and visit him with my father and take my
father there Wow and and let him find
peace and it was a an amazing few days
to be with my father of all places in
Israel in this British war cemetry which
is a beautifully kept Cemetery
surrounded by a very industrial town
Ramblers not the nicest of towns but the
cemetery itself is beautifully green and
they're an oasis and we found him there
marvelous marvelous let's move on to
your latest project we've talked about
forbidden music and tourism stats your
latest album escape to Hollywood is very
different but there is actually a
connection the word escape comes to mind
I mean again this is musicians from
Germany yeah this is from Germany from
from Vienna as well from all of Europe
who who fled the Nazis and having spent
15 years with the music for tourism
start and the musicians who did not
survive I thought it was time to look at
the other side to look at the the actual
escape itself and what that meant for
music and I wanted to try and trace the
origins of the Hollywood sound you know
what is the Hollywood sound where did it
come from
you know was it as I had suspected a
European tradition that met the sweeping
gestures of Hollywood at a time where
anything big went and what did that mean
for the film music of today so escape to
paradise is a real investigation of
where the greatest Hollywood sound came
from where that music came from and it
gave me the chance to firstly record the
corngold violin concerto one of my
favorite favorite pieces of all time
just an amazing piece but then to look
at some of the soundtracks to some of
the films that I adore I'm a huge film
buff
okay let's get a taste of Hollywood
let's escape to paradise
many of these musicians were forced out
of Europe by the Nazis in the 30s and
some emigrated to California where they
saw this challenge to take up the
composition of film music and as a
result they changed the way forever that
film music would sound
if I had to describe this album in three
words I mean I would have to say lavish
because lavish is the sound that we are
trying to get and I hope we've got I
would say nostalgic as well because
every one of these films takes us back
to some memory and the story of the
films and the composers in a way also
takes us back there and then the other
word of course is Hollywood
and we have a signed copy of Daniel
hopes latest CD escaped paradise to give
away just write to us at insite at DW de
and we'll put you in the draw please
remember to include your postal address
in case you are the lucky winner and I
can confirm to you it's a fabulous album
thank you very much it really is it's
lovely and some interesting people on it
including steam yes who you've known for
donkey's years I believe yes I have
actually
sting I've known since I was a little
boy curiously enough he bought the house
that belonged to you D menu in the house
in which I grew up and it was my mum
that showed him around when he first
came to visit the house so we go back a
long way
but four or five years ago we met at the
echo classic prize in Munich we had a
dressing adjacent dressing room where we
got talking and I told him I haven't
actually mentioned in my introduction of
all those one of the things how many
echos you've won and how many Grammys
you've been nominated for I'm sorry
sorry but we got talking and he was just
fascinated by the fact we were connected
through this house the house for him was
extremely important as it was for me and
so he invited me to be on one of his
albums if on a winter's night and we
have been in touch regularly since then
become very very good friends and what
was my dream to see if I could persuade
him to come on my album and I'm just
thrilled that he agreed to come to sing
a piece called a secret marriage which
many sting fans will know in fact the
music is actually about Hans iyslah
wrote new lyrics didn't he yes he'd
already written 'yes yeah 20 years ago
because he doesn't sing in German the
Texas by bet odd blessed but he wrote
his own lyrics which are beautiful and
and also very secretive and have a kind
of an escape feel to it so I asked him
if he'd agree to come and do a new
version of the song secret marriage and
with the music of hands eyes that was
exactly these escaped Hollywood
composers as
well so the whole thing fitted perfectly
I mean I know as you do this music is
extraordinary amusing it's but did you
get a bit I mean the classical music
world as the jazz world can be snobbish
at times did you get any sort of oh
you're not doing sort of film music are
you you know there's always gonna be
people that thought put-down film music
I think it's important to say firstly
this is not the music of transformers or
you know one of the films of today even
though there is good film music out
there there's no comparison to the
Golden Age of Hollywood and this music
by these composers I mean Korngold
McLaws Rocha Hans iyslah Kurt Vile
Stravinsky I mean these are enormous ly
talented composers and I think it's it's
good to broaden one's horizons I've
learnt a huge amount about this time
about this music about these composers
what the music meant to these people as
well it was a means not just to survive
but to support their relatives that they
were trying to get out of Europe at the
time you know they needed money to
smuggle people out of Germany and so it
was a means in order to really help
people at the same time created
extraordinary music with these great
images of the Golden Age of Hollywood so
you know for me there's nothing nicer
than that well I'm thrilled to ask you
if you would take up this fabulous
violin next year your gran airy and play
as something from from that sure would
this is a 1742 Granada Jesu called the
ex Lipinski named after a great polish
virtuoso Carol Lipinski who was a rival
of Paganini I believe is it's not your
is being given by a German family yes a
family in Germany very kindly bought it
for me and what it for place it at my
disposal and I'm feel very privileged
that I'm able to to borrow such an
amazing instrument and I'll just play
maybe an excerpt from Schindler's List
because that's a soundtrack which is
also on the album on escape to paradise
and is by John Williams not one of the
composers that escaped yeah him later on
and I
purposely selected three composers on
the album John Williams's one Thomas
Newman as another the son of Alfred
Newman the one of the creators of the
Hollywood sound and Morricone as well
composer European composer who went to
Hollywood and dominated Hollywood a few
decades after these dunnan's
but she endures this is what are the
greatest escape stories of all time
so for me automatically it was perfect
and then I just love it so I can show
you at least a little bit how the fiddle
sounds
oh thank you so much I'm so privileged
to hear that and I mean it is an
extraordinary sound close-up and I hope
everybody out there can hear it as well
I mean I know that you know a lot about
the violin you've written no mixing you
have written so buddy this was a
documentary wasn't it ses of the violin
I mean do you do you know people talk
about the varnish the wood what do you
think it is because nobody I mean we're
talking about one area Stradivari a
Marty's all 300 years ago
in Cremona wasn't it that's right I know
nobody seems to know one really knows I
mean you know it must have been
something in the water because the fact
that Cremona you know all places became
the center of violin making activity
forever is extraordinary it's a
beautiful town but you know why why
Cremona and and how they survived I mean
you not just now but I've seen you
playing it with some Gaston I'm thinking
cool careful Danny but but I mean
they're extremely strong well they're
you know you have to imagine these these
instruments are over 300 years old
so they've survived Wars they've
survived you know everything possible
you have to take care of it and you have
to make sure with all the climate
changes you know traveling a lot it
always has to go back to a violin makers
who has to treat it properly often the
wood actually opens up you get little
cracks because of humidity or extreme
dryness so the violin maker will for
example here on the sides will put a bit
of glue in and and stick it back
together again you you just have to
really take care of it but if you do
that it'll be here you know a lot longer
than we will be mmm and jokes are part
about the water what do you have your
own theory I mean these were just
geniuses I mean the same way that a da
Vinci created a new form of expression
that has been is still unique with all
the great artists that we have you can't
compare a da Vinci the same ways you
can't compare
a Stradivari or in this case a canary -
Jesu for me querida Jesu is even better
than the Stradivari really that's my
personal opinion there tend to be two
camps there's the Strad camp and there's
the del gesù camp and each one thinks
there's our better but for me a dirge a
zoo perhaps the fact that he wasn't his
famous Estrada vari he didn't live to be
in his nineties like Stradivari he
wasn't called upon by all the kings and
royalty to make instruments he was a
poor man struggling in the workshop of
Stradivari so he made a lot less and he
didn't actually have time to give the
perfect finish to the instruments for
example if you can see it but if you
look at the F holes on this instrument
you can see that they're actually quite
rugged at the top which you can see
where he took the knife and just carved
it it's not a perfect roundness ah and
if you look at Stradivari everything is
perfection it's like a you know a work
of art DOJ's ER was just like this he
did it he already didn't have time to
absolutely perfect it but that gives it
a visceral quality and the sound but
with the judges there was something
that's like a wild racehorse and that's
very exciting do you know I've got a
hundred other questions to ask you and
we've I'm just being told that we've
almost run out of time very quickly our
questionnaire we asked you we asked you
strange questions one I want to ask your
favorite German words you put down as
lifts kissing farts ah yes I think it's
just this outstanding word I mean
hovercraft is so easy in English it is
on fire so I think just bizarre beyond
belief don't you hope it's been a great
pleasure to have you in the studio today
won't you we'll finish on lift kissing
farts oi we've talked about many other
things yes and thank you so much for
playing your one area it's been a great
privilege thank you for having me yeah
and don't forget if you're interested in
winning this escape to Paradise do write
to us insight at DWD one lucky winner
only thank you very much for being with
us today it's been a great pleasure and
join us again at the same time next week
bye bye